okay we're underway we have a simple
model with reasonable performance where
do we go from here
well to make further gains we need to
stop treating the model as a black box
we need to open it up
and get visibility into what it's
learned and more importantly where it
still falls down
and then we can begin to look at some
ideas for how to improve it
one important way to to gain
understanding of our trained models is
to inspect the model weights
which features are strong positive
indicators for each relation
and what features are strong negative
indicators
the relaxed module contains a function
called examine model weights that makes
it easy to inspect
so here i show results for just four of
our 16 relations and in general i think
the features with large positive weight
are pretty intuitive
so for the author relation the biggest
weights are author books and by
uh for film performance we have starring
alongside and opposite
by the way i was a little bit puzzled
when i first saw alongside and opposite
because i thought
that
those are words that would naturally
appear between the names of two actors
not between the name of a film and the
name of an actor
um
what i did was i wrote a little bit of
code to
pull up the actual examples that
caused these weights to wind up being
large
and what i realized was there's a very
common pattern which is um
like x appeared in y alongside z
so x and z are actors y is a film x
appeared in y
alongside z
so you have y alongside z that indicates
that z is an actor that appeared in film
y
uh and i think something similar happens
for opposite so it um it does make sense
that these are uh strong indicators of
the film performance relation
uh for has spouse we have wife married
and husband i think this makes perfect
sense
the one that's a bit surprising is
adjoins
so for joints we have cordoba talux and
valet
it's odd to see specific place names
here
they certainly don't seem to express the
adjoins
um relation
wonder if anyone has a guess what's
going on i was really puzzled by this
and
so again i wrote a bit of code to find
the specific examples that contributed
to this result i looked for examples
where the two edge dimensions stand in
the a join's relation and these terms
these specific terms appear in the
middle
and when i looked at the examples i
realized that what's going on is that
it's very common to have
lists of geographic locations
so a comma b comma c comma d
and in such lists it's not uncommon that
just by chance a and c or a and d
stand in the a joins relation maybe it's
a list of provinces in a country
and of course some of those provinces
are adjacent to each other so if a
adjoins c or a adjoins d
that will tend to make b b
appear
as a positive indicator for the a joins
relation and especially if the corpus
just happens to contain several such
examples
so i think that's what contributed
to
this puzzling result
the features with large negative weights
look a bit more haphazard
but i think that's not surprising it's
kind of what you expect
for uh for this kind of linear model
by the way
you can fiddle with the code that prints
this out and here it just prints the top
three
but you can fiddle with the code there's
actually a parameter that tells you it
tells it how many
of the top of the list to print and so
you can print much longer lists and
for many of the relations
the top 20 even the top 50
features all look very plausible and
intuitive and it's quite satisfying to
see those
those results come out
another way to gain insight into our
model is to use it to discover new
relation instances that don't currently
appear in the kb
in fact as we discussed last time this
is the whole point of building a
relation extraction system to augment a
kb
with knowledge extracted from natural
language text at scale
so the the decisive question is can our
model do this effectively
we can't really evaluate this capability
automatically because we have no other
source of ground truth than the kb
itself
but we can evaluate it manually by
examining kb triples that aren't in the
kb
but which our model really really thinks
should be
in the kb so we wrote a function to do
this um
it's called find new relation instances
and
um you can go look at the code here's
how it works it starts from corpus
examples
containing pairs of entities that don't
belong to any relation in the kb
so these are the um these are what we
described last time as negative examples
we'll consider each such pair of
entities as a candidate to join each
relation
so we'll take the cross product of all
of those entity pairs
and relations
um we'll apply our model
to all of those candidate kb triples
and we'll just sort the results by the
probability assigned by the model in
order to find the most likely new
instances of each relation
so we'll find the candidate kb triples
that aren't currently in the kb
but which the model believes
have really high probability of being
valid
let's see what we get when we run it um
here are the results for the adjoins
relation
notice that the model assigned a
probability of 1.0 to each of these
pairs it is totally convinced that these
pairs belong to the adjoins relation
um but the results are
well let's be honest the results are
terrible
uh almost all of these pairs belong to
the contains relation which by the way
isn't actually one of our 16 relations
but um
intuitively they should belong to a
contains relation
not the a joins relation you could make
a case maybe for mexico and atlantic
ocean
uh belonging to the joints relation but
um
i mean to be honest even that one is a
stretch
uh one other thing worth noting whenever
the model predicts that x adjoins y it
also predicts that y adjoins x
you might for a moment think that the
shows that the model has understood
that adjoins is a symmetric relation
um unfortunately
no that's not what's going on it's just
an artifact of how we wrote the simple
bag of words featurizer that simple bag
of words featurizer makes no distinction
between forward and reverse examples so
it has no idea which one comes first and
which one comes second
and that will be true for asymmetric
relations just like uh for symmetric
relations
so this is not a very promising start
it's um
i mean we saw
a very good a
pretty good quantitative evaluation for
this model
so this is a little bit surprising
let's see what we get for
some other relations so here are the
results for the author relation
and these look a lot better
once again all of the probabilities are
one
but this time
every single one of these predictions is
correct
well not quite actually because
the book is supposed to appear first
like oliver twist and the author second
charles dickens so this first one
actually is correct
the second one is backwards it has the
author first and the book second
our model is completely ignorant of
order so it's just as likely to put
things in reverse
but if you ignore that
if you're willing to imagine that we
could easily fix that then the results
look great
we could put all of these triples right
into our kb and we'd have a bigger and
better kb because of it
this is relation extraction at its
finest
this is what we wanted
here are the results for the capital
relation and it's a similar picture uh
all of the probabilities are 1.0 the
ordering is
frequently reversed it's very haphazard
but if you put that aside
the results look very good
you could quibble perhaps with
deli here i mean the capital of india is
really new delhi
but new delhi is part of delhi so
you know it's close
still overall
i think this looks really good
let me show you one more this is this is
the last one i'll show these are results
for the worked at relation
and here the results are more mixed
uh so we have stan lee and marvel comics
sure if you can say that elon musk
worked at tesla motors then you can say
that stan lee worked at marvel comics
and while we're at it uh genghis khan
worked at the mongol empire sure why not
um
but the rest are nonsense
so why
what happened here well when you
encounter surprising and mysterious
results in your model output it's really
good practice to go dig into the data
and investigate
and this is called error analysis and i
want to show you a couple examples of
that now
so first let's see if we can figure out
what happened with louis chevrolet and
william c durant
um first let's look up the corpus
examples containing these two entities
i'm only going to look up the examples
that have them in this order
um i should look them up in the other
order as well and as a matter of fact i
did i'm just not going to put that on
the slide i'm just going to focus on
what happens in this order
so i'm going to look up these examples
and print out what they look like and
here's what we get
there are 12 examples and they all look
identical
actually i didn't print the full context
here if you look at the code closely
you'll see that i'm printing the suffix
of the left and the prefix of the right
so there's more context further out on
left and right and if you did see the
full context you would realize that the
examples do differ slightly
but they're very very similar they're
near duplicates i mentioned this last
time that this is one of the warts of
this data set it contains a lot of
near-duplicate examples and i think this
is an unfortunate consequence of the way
the
sample was constructed the way the web
documents that this corpus was based on
were sampled from the web
and it seems like that's bitten us here
but it still leaves a question why
why did that repetition lead the model
to predict
that this pair belongs to the worked at
relation because
it doesn't look obvious that that's the
right relation here
i suspect that it's because of the word
founder
because x being a founder of y
strongly implies that x worked at y
and actually we can check this it's not
that hard to write some code to inspect
the weight that was assigned to the word
founder
in the model for the workdat relation
so here's a little bit of code that does
that
uh and sure enough in the model for
workdate the word founder gets a weight
of 2.05
which is pretty large if you look at the
distribution of weights it's a
relatively large one i i forget exactly
but i think it's in the top 10.
it's a relatively uh significant quite
significant uh feature for this model
uh so that's what happened we've got 12
examples each of them is contributing a
sizable weight and the result is that
the model is completely convinced
that um that this is the right that this
that the
worked at relation holds here
by the way i didn't check but i'm
confident
that the founder the model for the
founders relation we'll also predict
that the founder relation holds here an
understanding of
what went wrong here
could help to stimulate some ideas for
how to fix it
um i don't think i'll i think i won't i
mean i have some ideas i think i won't
give them away but um
i hope this underscores the value of
error analysis you really want to
understand when you see weird results
you really want to understand what's
going on in your data that led to these
weird results
let me show you one more example that
has a bit of a different flavor let's
look at what's going on with homer and
the iliad
i wrote a little bit of code to
investigate this one too
and i'm not gonna show the whole
investigation
but i'm just gonna cherry pick the most
informative results
so one thing that i notice is that there
are a lot of examples for homer and
iliad in fact uh there are 118 of them
just in that direction there's more in
the reverse direction
that's impressive
but again by itself it doesn't explain
why worked at
looked like a good prediction by the way
i did check to see if it was the same
explanation as last time a lot of near
duplicates it's not that's not what's
going on here
but um
the next thing i did was to write some
code to count up the most common middles
that join homer and iliad across these
118 examples
and so that code looks like this
and here are the results um and there
was one middle that strongly dominated
and it's apostrophe s
so as in homer's
iliad
um
so that makes sense because clearly the
possessive can indicate
the author relation you expect to see
homer's iliad and jane austen's pride
and prejudice and many other similar
uh similar formulations
but the apostrophe s can equally well
indicate the work dat relation as in um
tesla's elon musk or microsoft's bill
gates
um so this apostrophe s is really highly
ambiguous
just to confirm that this
is actually
significant to the result that we saw
let's check
what weight was assigned to apostrophe s
in the model for work dat
so this code is similar to the code on
the previous slide but this time we're
looking for the weight for apostrophe s
and it turns out that the weight was
0.58
okay it's not a huge weight but it's not
small either and this feature occurred
51 times across the corpus
so i think that's what happened we had
a
you know
non-trivial amount of weight
um that got added up 51 times and we
wound up with a really big contribution
and the model feeling really confident
about this relation
so again thinking about this problem
might suggest some strategies for how to
reduce
that ambiguity the the fundamental
problem here is that apostrophe s is
highly ambiguous
um
a good question to ask yourself is is
there other information in the sentence
that could help to distinguish
the author relation
from the worked at relation
and i think there is again i don't want
to give too much away but i think
there's other evidence in these
sentences that could help to tease apart
these two relations and this kind of
error analysis is really indispensable
to the model development
process now for the homework and the
bake off we're going to turn you loose
to find ways to improve this baseline
model
and there are a lot of possibilities
one area for innovation is in the
feature representation we pass to the
learning algorithm
so far we've just used a simple bag of
words representation but you can imagine
lots of ways to enhance this so you
could use
word embeddings like the glove
embeddings
you could use a bag of words
representation that distinguishes
between forward and reverse context
you could use bi-grams or longer engrams
you could leverage the part of speech
tags that we have in the corpus
or information from wordnet
much of the early work on relation
extraction relied heavily on syntactic
features so maybe try that
and so far we've used features based
only on the middle phrase the phrase
between the two entity mentions you
could also try using information about
the entity mentions themselves for
example the entity types
or you could try deriving features from
the left and right context there are a
lot of possibilities for
richer feature representations
there's also a lot of room for
innovation with the model type
our baseline model is a simple linear
model optimized with logistic regression
that's a good place to start but there
are many other possibilities
if you want to stick with linear models
you could use an svm
and sklearn makes that easy
or you could experiment with neural
networks you could use a simple
feed-forward neural network as a drop-in
replacement for our linear model
or since examples can be a variable
length you might consider a recurrent
neural network like an lstm
if you go this way you'll have to think
carefully about how to encode the input
if the input is just the middle phrase
things are probably relatively
straightforward
but if you want to include the entity
mentions or the left and right context
you might need to think carefully about
how to demarcate the segments
or you could use a transformer based
architecture like bert's although the
quantity of training data that we have
available here might be a bit small
i think all of these are potentially
interesting and fruitful directions for
exploration and i think you can have a
lot of fun with this
you